watch thefts are on the rise in the UK
here's everything you need to know
[Music]
well these pieces alone are worth more
than a quarter of a million pounds
watches have rocketed in value in recent
years because the demand is so high from
so many people that has been fueled by
social media and also supply issues
during lockdown when they weren't being
made as much and of course if you're a
thief something like this is pretty
small it's easy to conceal easy to move
and if you sell it on well you can make
a huge amount of money
there were over 11 000 watches stolen in
England and Wales last year and that
number has nearly doubled since 2015
it's most Rife in London but it's
happening across the country since 2019
for example in the West Midlands watch
thefts has increased by 450 percent
[Music]
watch leaves can be opportunistic but
they're also quite clever in the areas
they choose to stalk to wait outside you
might see them by a high-end restaurant
or bar looking out for people and seeing
the value of their watches as they go in
and out we know they can also use social
media if you post a picture of your
expensive watch with a live location
well they know where to find you
foreign
we know these thieves have used knives
machetes even guns in the past and there
have in some extreme cases being people
killed over their watches
[Music]
well no matter what the value of your
watch there are a few really simple
things you can do to protect yourself
including covering up the watch with
something like a sleeve when you're out
about and not drawing too much attention
to it keep an eye out for anybody who
might be paying a bit too much attention
to you or your watch Maybe by asking you
the time so they can get a better look
at it and also really crucially don't
post pictures in real time with your
location on social media